and number five for me would have to be
50 cent
for sure 50 cent on some rapping now
you're like you're right you could you
could
be related to 50. i said before i get
that a lot uh i said before
um you said jaw rule over 50 when we
talked about first see this is where
this that got confused
up when i was kicking it with the girls
i would play more
gyro now but you wouldn't know that
though so
the audio back when i kicked it off
right and here it was like what
i'm like bro i'm not saying i don't [ __ ]
with 50. i'm saying i just played a lot
more
job i don't recall it that did as
diplomatic
we're going to run it back we're going
to run it back if i'm lying you was
[ __ ] careful
you was jaw rule over 50 like no it's
never over 50. it's just
i listened to ja rule a lot more growing
up but then as i got older and got into
you know finding a clip what's up yeah
no it's good it's on uh
it's on youtube yeah we'll find it we'll
put it in there but as i got older
um 50 related to me more but as a kid
them gyru melodies was
was catchy as [ __ ] i did not [ __ ] the
only driver
out of my [ __ ] with was vinny benny
betty vichy man so you don't [ __ ] with
336 rules
you don't [ __ ] with uh i was out on all
that [ __ ] man the last temptation nope
i like anybody i like betty i'm taking
care of the murdering school after we
wrap this up
i was hoping that i was opening murder i
was hoping murder inc was going to be
whole job ruling dmx and then
you know because they were supposed to
they did that record together but yeah
after vani vettivici when he started
doing all that i was just like you know
what this ain't for me
bro josh it wasn't for me bro no he had
i mean he had great hit records and like
i went to an old school concert a few
years ago with my wife and
but he lyrically no it's him in the shot
he's busy though
like you [ __ ] is [ __ ] punani vajani
your monologue is getting tired so it's
time to ride so take off that silly
chain put back
on your watch i'm on fire highly dipped
and octane let
but i'm straight benny betty vichy was
my [ __ ]
shout out to giant 50 man i know you
know and have issues
like i went to i went to a show and it
was him and ashanti at microsoft theater
and i was like damn this [ __ ]
has some joints for sure
bro yeah big hits but i like but at the
same time i'm like i was
like i i wasn't [ __ ] with it like i
also like
outside of country grammar i didn't i
was also i felt the same way about
another oh no we're not about to do this
no because i [ __ ] loved country
grammars
but nellyville and all that [ __ ] you
didn't like nellyville i'm good man
i liked i'm number one but like once
look as a kid once you start
you didn't like sweating suit hell no
now
you didn't like my placement [ __ ] no
i don't think anybody liked that song
besides you
listen country grammar was incredible
fire so the second album wasn't dope it
wasn't for me
with dilemmas not for me come on kid